la detención de la ex líder interina
jeanine áñez ha desatado fuertes
protestas en toda bolivia
concentraciones en las principales
ciudades del país condenando un juicio
político hemos comprobado que este
gobierno al estilo venezolano no quiere
por ningún medio que se respete la
voluntad popular
que es no queremos más con una dictadura
fascista en el poder la oposición de
derecha y de centro niega que haya
existido un golpe de estado en noviembre
de 2019 como afirma el gobierno
socialista que regresó al poder en
octubre pasado al acusar al gobierno de
agnès de derrocar a evo morales
contenta nunca haber vuelto
en cochabamba la ciudad del líder
izquierdista evo morales
una multitud también salió a las calles
a pedir la liberación de áñez
[Aplausos]
la detención de ya ni nadie que dice ser
víctima de una persecución política ha
provocado desde el sábado numerosas
reacciones en bolivia y en el extranjero
la portavoz adjunta del departamento de
estado en washington pidió que se
respete el debido proceso la oea instó a
la liberación de los detenidos en el
poder de noviembre de 2019 a noviembre
de 2020 la expresidenta áñez fue puesta
en detención preventiva durante cuatro
meses en una cárcel de mujeres en la paz